[Musique]
réchauffement climatique hausse de 3%
des émissions de gaz carbonique
diminution de 40% de la couche d'ozone
au pôle nord
autant d'actualité scientifique
alarmantes publiées par les équipes de
l'institut de recherche pierre simon
laplace ipsl dont le siège se situe à
l'eau vs q le nouvel observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
l'objectif de l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin s'est développé
dans l'avenir ces recherches que l'on
appelle intégré entre la compréhension
du fonctionnement du système climatique
en particulier
et puis les réponses de la société aux
grands bouleversements globo on est
école interne de l'université c'est à
dire conforme effectivement des
étudiants au niveau master à tout ce qui
concerne les sciences de l'environnement
de l'économie et du territoire et comme
ça on peut former les gens aux métiers
de demain autour du développement
durable
inauguration de ce campus de 30 mille
mètres carrés ce lundi 4 avril soit près
de deux ans après son ouverture mais
latente n'est pas une nouveauté dans ce
projet initié il ya presque vingt ans
finalement la persévérance et les
financements ont réussi à faire sortir
de terre l'observatoire sur un budget
global de près de 32 millions d'euros
70% ont été prises en charge par la
région ile de france
c'est un des lieux universités de
recherche que nous avons le plus financé
mais parce que il y allait au fond d'une
crédibilité française sur la question de
l'observation climatique l'adoption
d'atmosphère la question de la couche
d'ozone et caetera et je crois qu'en
rassemblant ici la plupart des
chercheurs pluridisciplinaires sur ce
sujet y compris dans les sciences
sociales
je crois qu'on fait un travail
exemplaire ce sont vraiment les
meilleurs chercheurs on peut dire de
notre communauté qui sont abrités sous
cet observatoire
c'est grâce aux équipes du latmos du lcr
notamment que nous sommes si bien
positionné aujourd'hui pour pour être
entré dans le classement de shanghai est
c'est aussi des domaines où il ya
énormément de formation prochaine étape
de ce campus universitaire la
construction de logements étudiants et
la création d'une maison de l'étudiant
un lieu de vie consacrée aux activités
des étudiants
[Musique]
ce dimanche 15 juillet 6000 supporters
se sont rendus au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour assister
à la finale de la coupe du monde france
croatie il n'aura pas le coup d'envoi la
fan zone affichent déjà complet ça c'est
la france et je lui ai entendu plusieurs
fois ce mot bon d'écouter voilà on est
tous très heureux
maintenant bien sûr on attend le le
résultat final musique à fond les
supporters se sont échauffés avant le
coup d'envoi avec des chants qui
laissait présager une belle soirée
bien accueilli
enfin retentit la marseillaise dans
l'enceinte sportive pour accompagner
l'entrée des joueurs sur le terrain
l enthousiasme laisse ensuite place au
stress et enfin le premier but français
arrive
à
un avantage de courte durée les croates
égalise laissant place aux doutes chez
supporteurs français puis antoine
griezmann redonne l'avantagé aux bleus
sur penalty avant la mi temps
lorsqu'on bien figurer c'est ce qui
revient à 83,6 domine mais
mais voilà il ya deux ans il ya deux ans
ma gueule et c'est pas fini c'est pas
finir à la voir c'est donc moins de 15
minutes après le retour des vestiaires
l'équipe de france fait le break 3
tu viens le quatrième but de killian mba
pays
malgré la réduction du score de la
croatie la france s'impose 4 à 2 et
ajoute une deuxième étoile sur son
maillot
la fête s'est ensuite poursuivie à
l'extérieur du vélodrome nationale
rendez vous dans quatre ans pour une
nouvelle coupe du monde et pourquoi pas
une troisième étoiles brodées sur le
maillot
[Musique]